والان ننتقل الى عمان العاصمه حيث هناك
انباء جديده نقلا عن الامن الاردني بان
هناك عمليه امنيه ادت لمقتل اا المجتبه في
بقتل نائب مدير امن معان وذلك خلال عمليه
دعم واضاف الامن الاردني ان ثلاثه من
افراده قتلوا واصيب خمسه خلال مداهمه
المجتبه به
وافاد مراسل الجزيره في الاردن ان الاجهزه
الامنيه اعتقلت مساء الاحد رئيس بلديه
معان السابق ماجد الشراري اثناء مغادرته
الى منزله من تجمع اضراب الشاحنات في
مدينه معان كما اعتقل الامن ايضا الشيخ
ياسر احمد الخطاب يعد كل من الشراره
والخطاب من المؤثرين في اضراب السائقين
احتجاجا على رفع اسعار المحروقات
[موسيقى]
وينضم الان الينا من عمان مدير مكتبنا حسن
الشوبكي اذا حسن نريد ان نعرف تفاصيل اكثر
لو سمحت عن عمليه الدم هذا التي ادت الى
مقتل المجتبى فيه ولافت ايضا استعمال
الامن اللي مصطلح مشتبه فيه حتى الان اييه
يعني بمعنى هل هناك تحقيق من ان الشخص
الذي تم اااه القضاء عليه هو فعلا من قام
بالعمليه
نعم ليلى ال ال المداهمات لم تتوقف منذ
يعني يوم الجمعه الماضيه اليوم الذي يعني
شاهدت ليلته اييي مقتل العقيد عبد الرزاق
الدلابيح نائب مدير شرطه معان
المداهمات هذه استمر حتى معها الاعتقالات
البيان المختطف للامن العام الاردني يقول
يعني كما جاء فيه قبل قليل ان ثلاثه من
افراد الامن قد قتلوا في مداهمه همم
اصيبتها خمسه اخرين وتم اعتقال ثمانيه همم
كما قلنا البيان مختبر وعندما يقول ان
التحقيقات لا تزال الجاريه
يعني هذه تشير لان هنالك ما معلومات ايضا
اضافيه ستظهر يبدو فيما يبدو في ساعات
المقبله لكن البيان ايضا قال لان
العمليه الامنيه ادت لمقتل المجتمع به في
قتل مدير شرطه معان واا هذه
المساله يعني دخلت في ايضا في تفاصيل اخرى
حيث اا اوضح البيان ان ال- ال- المجتمع به
الذي قتل في هذه المداهمه هو من حمله
الفكر التكفيري على حتى قول البيان الا
يبدو انه هنالك يعني همم
عمليه مستمره للامن
والاعتقالات طالت ليلى ايضا في اليوم
الماضي وما قبله نحو 44 يعني شخصا وكان
يعني بالامس تم فبط اا يعني اضراب الشائح
اضراب الشاحنات في معان تم فضه بالقوه بعد
ان طلب الامن من الجميع ان يقاتره وعندما
يعني همم بعد بعد فتره تدخل الامن واستخدم
الغاز
السائقين في مدينه معان وتم اعتقال همم
ماجد الشراري همم رئيس بلديه معان السابق
وكذلك الشيخ ياسر احمد الخطاب كل هذا يشير
الى ان ما تواعد فيه وزير الداخليه في
مؤتمر الصحفي همم عصر يوم الجمعه الماضي
يتم تنفيذه من خلال الوصول الى من هم
في ال ال العقيده الدلابيح واا هذا البيان
المقتضب يحتاج ايضا الى تفاصيل لاحقه
ستظهر فيما يبدو بما ان التحقيقات ما تزال
جاريه والحديث ثمانيه همم اعتقل في هذه
المداهمه
ولكن العدد الذي يعني همم كانوا يعني
يتحايل الامن في هذه المداهمه يبدوا الرقم
كبير عندما نقول ان هنالك مقتل ثلاثه من
افراد الامن واصابه خمسه هذا هذا الشيء
بشكل
عنيفه واستخدم فيها سلاح كثير همم
ساعات المقبله همم لان هذه الاسماء مفتوحه
بشكلها الامني وحتى بشكلها
السياسه يعني لا يوجد
حتى اللحظه حلو الحاسمه بالامس كان هنالك
جدل في الكرك حول مساله اضراب ال ال الذي
اعلنت عنه بلديه الكرك
اليوم الحديث اعضاء المجلس البلدي قال انه
سيوقفون
هذا الاغراض او هذه الوقفه الاحتجاجيه همم
رئيس بلديه الكرك قال انه ماضا في ذلك
يعني الازمه المفتوحه بشكل اساسي والامري
وحتى الميداني فيما يتعلق يعني تعامل همم
المدربين او المحتاجين او الغاضبين لكن
ال- ال- همم
المتعلق به البيان الاخيره الذي صدر قبل
قليل ااه يعني يشير لان الامن توصل الى
معلومات